la influenza o gripe es una infección
viral contagiosa que ataca a la nariz
garganta y pulmones
puede causar fiebre escalofríos
destilación nasal dolor de garganta tos
dolores musculares y cansancio el virus
de la gripe es sumamente pequeño y solo
se puede ver con un microscopio
electrónico dentro del virus el material
genético contiene la información para
hacer más copias del mismo virus una
capa protectora proteica protege
eficazmente el material genético
mientras el virus viaja entre las
personas o animales que infecta una
cubierta exterior permite al virus
infectar las células mezclándose con la
membrana exterior de las células de la
cubierta exterior brotan picos de
moléculas proteicas el virus de la gripe
usa sus picos h como llave para entrar a
las células
los picos n permiten que las copias del
virus se separen de las moléculas
infectadas para infectar a más células
hay 17 tipos de picos h conocidos y 9
tipos de picos en que los científicos
usan para nombrar a diferentes tipos de
virus de la gripe como el virus h5n1
usted se contagia de gripe por tocar un
objeto que contenga el virus oa través
de la exposición de los fluidos del
cuerpo de personas o animales
contagiados con el virus cuando una
persona infectada habla tose o estornuda
las gotas portadoras del virus de la
influenza pueden llegar hasta la nariz o
boca de quienes la rodean y de ahí pasan
a los pulmones una vez que está dentro
de su cuerpo el virus de la influenza
entra en contacto con las células de su
nariz garganta o pulmones el pico h del
virus inserta un receptor molecular en
la membrana celular sana como si fuera
una llave en una cerradura
esta acción permite que el virus penetre
en la célula
entonces el virus viaja dentro de un
saco hecho con las membranas de sus
células hacia el núcleo celular
entonces la cubierta viral y el saco de
la membrana celular se combinan
permitiendo al material genético viral
salirse del saco y entrar al núcleo
el material genético viral roba la
energía y materiales del núcleo celular
para hacer miles de copias de sí mismo
una parte del material genético se sale
del núcleo se une a los ribosomas en
donde están las partes de la célula que
producen proteínas los ribosomas usan la
información del material genético para
producir otras proteínas virales tales
como los picos h y n el aparato de golgi
es una estructura de almacenamiento
dentro de la célula la cual transporta a
los picos h y n dentro de vesículas que
se mezclan con las membranas celulares
todas las partes necesarias para crear
un nuevo virus se reúnen debajo de las
membranas celulares entonces un nuevo
virus empieza a brotar de la membrana
celular durante este proceso el virus
recién creado se atasca en la membrana
celular cuando un pico viral h
obstruye los receptores de membrana sin
embargo el virus tiene forma de evitar
este problema el pico viral n libera el
virus cortándolo del receptor
ahora hay nuevos virus de influenza
libres para infectar más células y
provocar la aparición de la gripe
si usted tiene gripe su médico puede
recetar le oseltamivir por vía oral o
zanamivir que se suministra mediante un
inhalador para acelerar la velocidad de
recuperación o para reducir el riesgo de
complicaciones estas medicinas
antivirales detienen el virus de la
influenza evitando que el pico viral n
libere el virus esto causa que los
nuevos virus se adhieran a la superficie
de las células de tal forma que no
puedan escapar e infectar otras células
la mejor forma de auto protegerse de la
gripe es vacunarse contra la gripe cada
año puede vacunarse con una inyección
que contiene varios tipos de virus
muertos o puede recibir la vacuna
también con una spray nasal que contiene
varios tipos de virus vivos pero muy
débiles
la vacuna expone al cuerpo a varios
tipos de virus de influenza que son
demasiado débiles para causar infección
pero lo suficientemente fuertes para
estimular una respuesta de inmunidad dos
semanas después las células del sistema
inmunológico producen marcadores
conocidos como anticuerpos que son
específicos para los tipos de
a la que usted estuvo expuesto los
anticuerpos se unen a cada virus de la
gripe y evitan que se adhieran a sus
células los anticuerpos también se
pueden adherir a más de un virus de la
gripe causando que los virus se agrupen
el sistema inmunológico responde a las
señales de los anticuerpos envolviendo y
destruyendo el grupo de virus
si luego usted se expone de nuevo a este
tipo de gripe su cuerpo reconoce los
virus y los destruye por lo que usted no
volverá a tener gripe de esos mismos
virus para una protección continua
contra nuevos virus de gripe será
necesario vacunarse cada año